This problem was a little harder than the others. If you wrote ns or no
solution, that's great. Let's see why the answer is no solution. When I'm
solving an absolute value inequality, the first thing I need to do is make sure
I isolate the absolute value. To isolate the absolute value, in this case, I
have to divide both sides by negative 3. To isolate the absolute value, I have
to divide both sides of the inequality by negative 3. When I divide the left
side by negative 3, negative 3 over negative 3 is 1, so I'm simply left with the
absolute of x minus 4. Now, since I divided both sides of this equation by
negative 3, we have to remember to switch the direction of the inequality. And 6
divided by negative 3 is negative 2. Now, let's think about this problem. The
absolute value of x minus 4 is less than negative 2. We know that absolute
values are always positive so can the absolute value of x minus 4 ever be a
negative number or much less, less that negative 2? No, this can never happen.
Since the absolute value can never be negative, this inequality has no solution.
Let's go on to Chapter 3, where we're going to learn about lines.